le dernier vice roi des Indes voilà un
film que j'ai découvert cet été à une
période généralement il n'y a rien à la
télévision c'était sur une grande chaîne
publique et j'ai tellement aimé ce film
qui parle de la partition de l'Inde
juste après que l'Empire britannique est
quitté le pays j'ai tellement aimé ce
film que je suis retourné au cinéma pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que c'est un
film absolument superbe moi qui ai vu
énormément de beaux paysages ou de beaux
costumes ou de beaux décors j'ai été
bluffé par la perfection des costumes et
des décors par ailleurs il y a une
figuration exceptionnelle des milliers
d'Indiens qui croisent la route
notamment de l'Orne bounbatten qui est
là pour assurer la session en douceur la
transition douceur entre l'Empire
britannique l'Inde et le Pakistan ce
film est interprété par HUG Bonneville
également guilian Anderson qui a le rôle
de l'épouse de Lord Mountbatten et qui
joue avec une grande finesse c'est un
film très délicat il y a en fait à la
fois de la politique extrêmement
intéressante puisque c'est une page de
mars 1947 que peu de gens connaissent et
par ailleurs il y a également une très
belle romance entre deux je dirais
domestique employés de l'ambassade
d'Angleterre et ces deux indiens dont
l'un et l'ancienne acteur de Slumdog
Millionaire vont avoir une liaison pas
si systématique que ça ça n'est pas une
romance bollywoodienne c'est une vraie
histoire d'amour qui se fait avec
beaucoup d'épreuves donc on vibre tout
du long du film et voilà pourquoi j'ai
eu tout le temps envie de revoir ce film
Le Dernier vice roi des Indes de
gürinder Shada fine de 2017 accessible
aux Européens bien Canadiens c'est un
spectacle magnifique bon spectacle